ça fait maintenant 7 mois que le conflit
ferrage en Ukraine mais comment ça se
passe concrètement pour les agriculteurs
sur le terrain on a voulu savoir
une guerre qui laisse des traces en
ville comme à la campagne
[Musique]
on s'attend à ce que la récolte en
Ukraine soit amputée du tiers cette
année mais une moisson tout de même
honorable dans les circonstances c'est
ce que confirme des agriculteurs avec
qui nous avons repris contact
souvenez-vous Alex licite ça est à la
tête d'une grande entreprise agricole
nous lui avions parlé en mars dernier à
sa grande surprise ses chants ont
beaucoup produits cet été
not to get reesal je blague avec mon
équipe je leur dis on a tout essayé pour
ne pas que ça marche on a réduit les
engrais on n'avait pas les pesticides
qu'il fallait et pourtant c'est la plus
belle saison de culture que j'ai vu dans
le nord de l'Ukraine
on a des rendements de blés d'hiver de
près de 7 tonnes à l'hectare pour une
année comme celle-ci c'est très bon
mais la saison n'a pas été de tout repos
comme ailleurs en Ukraine une partie de
ces terres a été occupée par les Russes
quand les troupes de Vladimir Poutine se
sont retirés elles ont laissé derrière
elle un lourd fardeau
nous avons aidé ou déminages de 32000
hectares de terre
ont explosé en roulant sur des mines
donc on a perdu de la machinerie mais
Dieu merci tout le monde a survécu
chanceux la quantité de mines est
d'engins explosifs dispersés sur le
territoire fait aujourd'hui de l'Ukraine
le terrain le plus dangereux de la
planète pour les civils selon des ONG
spécialisées
en agriculture des milliers d'hectares
ont dû être abandonnés le déminage
complet prendra des années
tout le grand secteur agroalimentaire
crucial pour l'économie ukrainienne et
toucher on ne compte plus les attaques
sur des élévateurs à grands des
entrepôts d'engrais des étapes on estime
d’ailleurs que l'Ukraine a déjà perdu
plus de 50 000 vaches laitières la
compagnie d'alexlicitsa c'était doté
d'une toute nouvelle étape pour ses 1000
vaches juste avant la guerre elles n'ont
plus n'a pas échappé à l'invasion
des animaux étaient malades où ils ont
été tués par les Russes
dans le sud chez André pastouchenko la
situation est différente sa ferme de 350
vaches laitières dans un village près de
Kerson est situé au cœur d'une zone
contrôlée par les russes depuis les tous
premiers jours de la guerre vivant
autour de la ferme il y a eu beaucoup
d'explosions mais nous avons eu de la
chance parce que tous les collègues et
toutes les vaches sont encore en bonne
santé et tout il y a encore debout
depuis le début du conflit André gère la
ferme à distance car il travaille
désormais à l'effort de guerre au
printemps il a réussi à traverser la
ligne de front et à évacuer plusieurs
enfants de son village dans son fils
mais impossible ensuite de faire le
chemin inverse
c'était très important pour moi que mon
fils de 15 ans qui était en vacances à
la ferme au début du conflit puis
quitter cette zone de guerre
jusqu'à tout récemment il suivait au
quotidien les activités de la ferme
contre toute attente ces travailleurs
ont pu semer et récolter une partie des
champs
on a même fait de l'ensilage on a pu
récolter une partie de nos champs de
céréales l'or Giraud vache par exemple
mais s'il y a de quoi nourrir le
troupeau la ferme est coupée du reste du
monde
[Musique]
en ce moment il n'y a aucun moyen de se
faire livrer quoi que ce soit en
provenance de l'Ukraine par deux fois
c'est la Croix Rouge qui nous a apporté
des médicaments pour les animaux
impossible également de se procurer des
produits en apparence tout simple comme
le nettoyant pour l'équipement de traite
pour l'instant on achète du liquide à
vaisselle pour essayer de nettoyer le
gras dans les tuyaux ça ne fonctionne
pas très bien et évidemment la qualité
du lait en souffre
les agriculteurs Ukrainiens arrivent
malgré tout à produire mais exporter les
récoltes demeure toujours un enjeu trois
ports de la mer Noire sont ouverts à la
navigation depuis le début où mais les
volumes entreposés demeurent colossaux
l'Ukraine n'a retrouvé que 50% de sa
capacité d'exportation en
c'est impossible de livrer quoi que ce
soit au port parce qu'ils sont encore en
train d'exporter le grain de l'année
dernière
j'espère que nous pourrons commencer les
livraisons en novembre ou en décembre si
la corde tient toujours
l'entreposage de la nouvelle récolte
pose d'ailleurs problème partout au pays
les silos sont encore remplis de
céréales des greniers désaffectés datant
de l’époque soviétique ont même été
remis en fonction
Alex licite ça s'inquiète également pour
sa récolte de maïs et de tournesol qui
vient à peine de commencer dans le nord
de l'Ukraine le climat est humide et les
grains risques de pourrir si on les
entrepose telles qu'elles après la
récolte
on doit faire sécher les grains et pour
ça ça prend du gaz naturel sauf qu'il
n'y en a presque pas de disponible pour
des usages industriels mais
ligne de gaz va nous nuire
dans le sud chez André pastouchenko le
climat est très sec nul besoin de faire
sécher le grain mais il a d'autres
soucis depuis la contre-offensive
ukrainienne des dernières semaines et le
référendum la situation est très tendue
sa collègue qui dirigeait la ferme en
son absence a été arrêtée et les
autorités prorus ont désigné un nouveau
propriétaire qui doit prendre le
contrôle des lieux
comme pour bien d'autres agriculteurs en
Ukraine l'avenir est incertain
[Musique]